bonjour à tous La séance est
ouverte avant de commencer je voudrais
vous présenter tous mes vœux pour cette
nouvelle année qui commence à vous et à
vos
familles l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au
Gouvernement la première d'entre elles
va être posée par le président marlex
pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Ministre la seule question que
se posent les Français à la suite de
votre nomination à Matignon c'est est-ce
que ça va changer quelque chose pour
nous la France est toujours connaî
toujours une dette à bissal qui la place
au bord de la faillite les Français ont
de plus en plus de mal à boucler leur
fin de mois nos frontières sont toujours
des passoirs la violence explose on ne
peut plus se faire so dans de nombreux
départements nos épades manquent de tout
et on a désormais une crise du logement
sans précédent avec des salariés
condamnés à dormir dans leur voiture vos
défis c'est peu de le dire sont immenses
le seul remède c'est d'agir avec courage
même quand c'est difficile même quand
c'est unpulaire nous nous sommes quittés
en décembre sur l'adoption de la loi
immigration elle a suscité une crise qui
a fait imploser votre majorité
qui a fait imploser le gouvernement de
Madame borne notamment sur la question
de l'aide médicale d'État cette aide
sociale versée au bénéfice de
400000 clandestins coûte 1,2 milliards
aux Français c'estes mêmes français à
qui vous demandez de contribuer de
manière supplémentaire de 50 centimes de
plus par boîte de médicaments ou ces
Français à qui vous déremboursez un peu
plus les soins dentire votre
prédécesseur Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ainsi que le ministre de
l'Intérieur votre Ministre de
l'Intérieur s'était engagé devant Laur
représentation nationale à enfin réformé
laame pour la recentrer sur des soins
d'urgence et des soins vitaux allez-vous
tenir cet engagement quand nous
présenterez-vous un projet de loi je
vous remercie monsieur le Président la
parole est à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre
merci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le Président
marlex c'est la première fois que je
m'exprime dans cet hémicycle en tant que
Premier ministre et vous me permettrez
de commencer en remerciant le président
de la République pour sa confiance en
remerciant les membres du gouvernement
que j'ai proposé qui ont été nommés de
m'accompagner en remerciant la
représentation nationale pour son
accueil parmi
vous monsieur le Président
marlex en choisissant de me nommer
Premier ministre le président de la
République a choisi de nommer un
ministre du précédent
gouvernement parfaitement lucide sur la
situation que traverse notre pays et les
Français
oui notre pays traverse de très grands
défis comme le monde oui des Français
traversent de très grandes difficulté
oui il y a des Français qui doutent il y
a des Français qui souffrent il y a des
Français en colère des Français qui n'y
croient
plus et je le dis je ne tomberai jamais
dans le fatalisme consistant à penser
que les problèmes des Français ne
peuvent pas être réglés au contraire
parce que nous voyons aussi chaque jour
dans notre pays des Français qui
innovent qui investissent qui
travaillent qui s'engagent dans des
associations en solidarité avec les
Français des Français qui cherchent tout
simplement à faire progresser notre pays
à répondre aux attentes de leurs
concitoyens et je suis l'un d'entre eux
et les membres de mon gouvernement le
sont également j'aurai l'occasion
évidemment de présenter ma déclaration
de politique générale et nous aurons
l'occasion avancer sur un certain nombre
de chantiers ensemble je le
dis je suis lucide sur ces
difficultés est totalement mobilisé pour
y répondre notamment celle que vous avez
évoqué vous avez posé une question
s'agissant de l'immigration de notre
modèle social et de l'aide médicale
d'État un texte a été débattu au
Parlement un texte a été adopté le
Conseil constitutionnel en est saisi et
se prononcera
prochainement dans le cadre de ce texte
un débat a eu lieu sur l'aide médicale
d'État ellisabeth borne ma prédécesseur
a effectivement adressé un courrier en
prenant un engagement et cet engagement
sera tenu monsieur le Président marlex
j'aurai l'occasion dans ma déclaration
de politique général à revenir sur les
chantiers à venir sur la méthode de
travail mais vous l'aurez compris je
souhaite avancer avancer vite avancer
fort sur les préoccupations de nos
concitoyens pour permettre à notre pays
d'affronter les grands défis sont devant
lui je vous remercie je vous remercie
monsieur le Premier
ministre monsieur le
[Musique]
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
les beau mots c'est bien l'action c'est
mieux je vous rappelle que l'ame c'est
l'argent des Français c'est français à
qui vous demandez un effort sur leur
dépenses de santé il n'est pas de raison
que vous ne passiez pas très vite à
l'action sur laame on l'attend pour ce
début de l'année comme promis par votre
prédécesseur merci
beaucoup la parole est à
monur pour le groupe lot merci madame la
Présidente au moment où tout le monde se
souhaite des vœux de santé cette
dernière reste la principale
préoccupation des Français notamment
dans les territoires ruraux on constate
un manque de médecins en médecine de
ville on constate un manque de médecins
de personnel soignant dans nos hôpitaux
c'est un constat dans lesvuges comme
c'est un constat dans tout notre pays ce
problème prend son origine dans des
décisions politiques d'attendre il y a
40 ans mais depuis 7 ans nos concitoyens
ne voient pas de
changement la transformation du numérus
closus en numerus apartus n'a rien
changé Monsieur le Premier Ministre
quand quand avec le ministre de la Santé
la ministre de la santé la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur allez-vous
ouvrir plus largement l'accès aux études
de médecine quand allez-vous donner plus
plus de moyens aux universités pour
pouvoir former plus de
médecins de plus monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez annoncé lors d'un
déplacement 32 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour l'hôpital c'est en
réalité une excellente nouvelle ce
chiffre néanmoins est égal à la hausse
prévue et votée de la branche maladie
est-ce que cette hausse dont vous
parliez est réellement une hausse de 32
milliards pour notre hôpital pour ces
personnels ou alors est-ce un pur hasard
si elle correspond justement à la hausse
prévue dans par branche maladie dans le
projet de loi de financeces et Monsieur
Monsieur le Premier Ministre ces 32 ces
32 milliards d'euros seraient réellement
nécessaire pour notre hôpital
public je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame Catherine Vautrin ministre du
Travail de la santé et des solidarités
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs lesput
vous avez raison monsieur le député
neigelen c'est vrai que depuis 40 ans
notre pays a connu des difficultés en ce
qui concerne le nombre de médecins en ce
qui concerne bien évidemment les
personnels soignants mais vous l'avez
dit vous-même 40 ans et bien depuis 2019
nos dépenses d'assurance maladie londam
ont augmenté de près de 55 milliards
d'euros dont la moitié au bénéfice des
établissements de santé en réponse à la
crise de covid-19 le segéure de la Santé
a apporté des réponses aussi bien en
fonctionnement c'est la reconnaissance
des revalorisations salarial pour
l'ensemble des équipes soignantes mais
également des investissements 19
milliards d'investissements sur la
période 2020 2029 alors au-delà des
chiffres moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
mettre en avant ces investissements du
quotidien c'est le travail de ce que
vous avez voté Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés et c'est cela qu'aujourd'hui
nous allons mettre en place en ayant
effectivement des hôpitaux qui seront
des hôpitaux plus modernes plus verts
mais également des investissement qui
permettront comme au C de Remirmont
d'apporter des réponses en matière
d'offre de soins de qualité la
traduction concrète au service des
bassins de vie au service de nos
concitoyens trois maîtr mot vont guider
cette action accélérer ces
investissements les crédits sont là nous
devons aller plus vite deuxièmement
concrétiser les modernisations
troisièmement donner aux professionnels
de santé des conditions de travail
meilleur voilà le chemin ensemble dans
le respect et la discussion nous
avancerons merci beaucoup madame la
ministre monsieur neigelen madame la
ministre je ne remets pas en cause le
Ségure qui était en réalité une une très
bonne chose et il faut le saluer je vous
parle de former plus de médecins c'est
ça qu'on a besoin il manque il en faut
trois pour en remplacer un qui part en
retraite on a besoin de plus de médecin
mer beaucoupp merci
beaucoup la parole est à monsieur le
Président Maillard pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance
merci merci merci madame la Présidente
j'associe à ma question le président
matthi
monsieur le Premier ministre je souhaite
tout d'abord au nom de toute la majorité
présidentielle saluer votre nomination
comme nouveau chef du
[Applaudissements]
gouvernement votre nomination est le
gage de la volonté d'audace sil et de
renouvellement
que nous avons toujours incarné aux yeux
des
Français fidèle à ses valeurs et au
projet qui est le nôtre depuis 2017
celui du président de la République vous
avez exprimé votre ambition d'un
gouvernement centré sur l'action et les
résultats et ce au bénéfice de tous les
citoyens les chantiers disons-le sont
nombreux en premier il y a bien sr
l'école de la République don vousvez pri
absolue nous pouvons que le saluer
monsieur le Premier ministre mais il y a
également le respect de l'autorité et du
droit de la
sécurité la défense du pouvoir d'achat
et des classes moyennes la promotion de
la valeur travail oui la promotion de la
valeur
travail la préservation de notre modèle
social la maîtrise de nos finances
publiques ou encore l'accélération de la
transition
écologique tous ces défis il est
impératif que nous les relevions
ensemble si nous voulons que la France
de demain soit fidèle à elle-même fidèle
à son histoire dans cette perspective
Monsieur le Premier Ministre comment
entendez-vous dérouler votre action pour
les mois à venir je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président la parole
est à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Sylvain
Maillard quand j'ai été nommé Premier
ministre j'ai eu l'occasion d'indiquer
quelles étaient mes grandes priorités
oui comme vous je veux agir pour tous c
tous ces Français qui sont toujours au
rendez-vous de leur responsabilité qui
travaillent tous les jours qui bien
souvent se trouvve un peu trop au-dessus
pour bénéficier des aides sociales et
pas suffisamment haut pour s'en sortir
tout seul c'est à cette France là oui
que je veux m'adresser aussi et les
accompagner
oui monsieur le Président Maillard je
veux continuer à m'engager pour l'école
de la République j'ai eu l'occasion de
fixer un cap de prendre de première
décision en tant que ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
ce cap sera évidemment tenu nous devons
remettre de l'exigence et de
l'excellence à tous les étages l'école
n'est pas un Tapier roulant sur lequel
on se pose et on passe de classe en
classe sans vérifier si on a le niveau
remettre de l'exigence et de
l'excellence c'est ce que nous devons à
tous les élèves de France en matière
d'égalité des chances oui nous allons
agir et la ministre vient de l'indiquer
sur l'accès aux soins et pour la santé
de nos concitoyens ce qui est une très
grande priorité oui nous allons
poursuivre poursuivre notre
investissement pour la sécurité de nos
concitoyens pour les droits et dev voir
respecté en tout lieu dans la République
pour des familles au rendez-vous de
leurs responsabilités et de celle de
leurs enfants
et oui monsieur le Président Maillard
nous allons continuer à avancer aussi
pour la planification écologique cet
immense chantier de transformation et je
le dis je le dis les résultats que nous
avons obtenu en matière de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ces
derniers mois n'avait pas été connu dans
notre pays
auparavant nous allons poursuivre nous
allons
poursuivre à partir de là monsieur le
Président Maillard le président de la
République s'exprimera vous le savez ce
soir pour affirmer un cap il
m'appartiendra ensuite de présenter
devant la représentation nationale ma
déclaration de politique générale cette
déclaration de politique générale je
souhaite la construire et la nourrir
avec l'ensemble des forces politiques
représentées dans cet hémicycle et au
Sénat et donc je recevrai l'ensemble des
groupes politiqu représenté au Parlement
pour construire avec eux cette
déclaration de politique générale de la
même manière j'échangerai avec les
forces syndicales avec les associations
d'élus locaux je me déplacerai aussi sur
le terrain au contact des Français pour
nourrir cette feuille de route j'ai
proposé à la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qu'en conséquence la
déclaration de politique générale puisse
se tenir le 30 janvier prochain dans cet
hémicycle après ce travail de dialogue
de concertation avec l'ensemble de
celles et ceux qui sont prêts à
s'engager pour relever les défis au
service des
Français merci beaucoup monsieur le
monsieur le Premier
ministre la parole est à Madame pour le
rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre le théâtre
élyséen ferme ses portes ce soir mais la
nomination de votre gouvernement donne
déjà une idée du grand rendez-vous
promis par Emmanuel Macron l'axisme
judiciaire et place de prison non
construite monsieur Dupont Moretti reste
à la justice croissance quasi nul
déficit commercial record et dett qui
explos Monsieur le Maire reste à
l'économie bacle sécuritaire et chaos
migratoire monsieur Darmanin
s'autoreconduit au ministère de
l'Intérieur s'ajoute à la liste madame
oua Castera félicité pour le mensonge du
Stade de France ce qui depuis semble
d'ailleurs être une marque de fabrique
ou encore monsieur séjourné exfiltré en
catastrophe des élections européennes et
qui nous explique qu'il est compétent
parce qu'il a vécu à l'étranger mais
bien sûr en voilà un argument de poid
alors il y a pire monsieur le Premier
ministre que de vouloir tout changer
pour que rien ne change il y a ne rien
vouloir changer du tout à commencé par
la politique de saccage social de
fiscalité étouffante et de précarisation
généralisé que vous menez depuis bientôt
7 ans voici qu'au beau milieu de l'hiver
vous annoncez la hausse de 10 % des
factures d'électricité pour les ménages
monsieur hatal une inflation en baisse
ça reste une inflation les prix de la
nourriture des services et des biens
continuent d'augmenté et voici
maintenant 3 ans que les français payent
le litre d'essence près de 2 € monsieur
le Premier ministre si la problème est
structurel la réponse doit être
structurelle la solution réside dans les
taxes qui représente une part démesurée
des prix à la pompe comme de
l'électricité il faut d'urgence baisser
la TVA sur les produits énergétiques
maintenir le gel de la TI CFE et
instaurer enfin le taux zéro pour 100
produits de première nécessité après la
nouvelle hausse des prix du péage des
train ou encore de la viande allez-vous
enfin prendre conscience de la gravité
de la situation ou attendez-vous la
ruine définite
je
vousci je vousci la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno le ministre de l'Économie
des Finances de la souveraineté
industrielle numérique présames
etessieursputadame laputé la le pouvoir
d'achat est un sujet trop sérieux pour
se contenter de déclaration péremptoire
prenez la question de l'électricité et
du gaz qui est la principale raison de
l'inflation dans notre pays depuis 2 ans
cette majorité a mis en place un
bouclier sur l'électricité et le gaz qui
a mieux protégé la population française
que toutes les autres population
européenne
quand quand l'électricité a flambé et
que la facture d'électricité des
Français aurait dû doubler passant en
moyenne de 1000 à 2000 € nous avons pris
en charge la moitié de cette facture
1000 € vous madame la valallette et
votre groupe vous proposiez la baisse de
la TVA à 5 % ce qui aurait présenter 300
€ d'économie nous avons fait tro fois
mieux que vous sur le pouvoir d'achat et
je me permettrai de vous rappeler Madame
La Valette que nous n'aurions pas eu de
problème de pouvoir d'achat que nous
n'aurions pas eu de problème de flambber
des prix de l'électricité et du gaz si
votre ami Monsieur Vladimir Poutine
n'avait pas attaqué
l'Ukraine enfin Madame
lavette où
étiezvous où était votre groupe
madame ci de revaloriser les pensions de
retraite pour suivre l'inflation vous
avez voté contre quand nous avons décidé
de revaloriser les minimas sociaux vous
de revaloriser le barê de l'impôt sur le
revenu pour que les classes moyennes ne
payent pas davantage d'impôt sur le
revenu vous avez voté contre toutes les
revalorisations de pouvoir d'achat alors
un peu plus d'acte un peu plus de
décision aidez-nous dans notre combat
pour le pouir d'achat des
Français je vous remercie monur monsieur
le ministre madame la valallette
monsieur le ministre nous referons de la
France le paradis énergétique elle
devrait être pour les ménages et les
entreprises vous avez éteint la lumière
nous la rannulerons vivement 9 juin
merci
beaucoup la parole est à madame la
Présidente châelin pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre en laissant
Emmanuel Macron s'acaparer tous les
pouvoirs c'est notre démocratie qui est
en danger vous n'avez entre vos mains ni
votre destin ni celui de la France vous
êtes là par le bon vouloir du président
votre omomination est le choix de la
continuité rien d'étonnant alors que
vous renonciez à demander la confiance
de l'Assemblée nationale comme
manadborne vous êtes condamné à rester
l'exécutant zellé d'un président qui
s'imagine souverain d'un président qui
depuis maintenant 7 ans ne peut
constater la chute du soutien des
Français à sa politique pourtant de
remanement en remanement rien ne change
de la répression des gilets jaunes au
passage en force de la réforme des
retraites des soutiens au prédateur
contre la parole des femmes à la
connivance avec les profiteurs de la
catastrophe climatique des menaces
contre la Ligue des droits de l'homme à
la déchéance morale sur la loi
immigration de la promotion du
séparatisme scolaire à l'ascension des
corrompus par les riches et pour les
riches pourrait être le slogan de votre
gouvernement cette Assemblée nationale
est née de la volonté des Français de
mettre un terme au privilège du désir IR
de reprendre en main le contrôle de leur
destin un exécutif qui s'attaque au
contrepouvoir qui gouverne sans le
Parlement et qui décide de décider sans
les corps intermédiaire cela a un nom ça
s'appelle un régime ilbéral en France
nos institution sont une protection
elles ont vocation à s'assurer que le
président ne décide pas seul qui décide
dans l'intérêt général et qu'il décide
dans l'intérêt de tous les Français
alors Monsieur le Premier Ministre j'ai
une seule question est-ce que vous
fragiliserez notre
l'ért privil
deelques je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur le prier
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente châelin je remercie
d'avoir rappelé ce qui est la lettre de
la Constitution de la 5e République
c'est le président de la République qui
nomme le Premier ministre ça n'a pas ch
leses président de Chatelin je pourrais
répondre sur beaucoup des sujets que
vous avez évoqué permettez-moi
simplement de dire que j'ai été et que
je pense que beaucoup l'ont été aussi
ici heurte d'un certain nombre de termes
que vous avez
employé opposer la France et la
République française l'opposer à la
démocratie parler de régime illibéral
quel mépris pour tous les habitants du
monde qui se battent pour les droits de
l'homme dans des pays où les droits de
l'homme ne sont pas garantis
madame la Présidente si nous étions dans
un régime illibéral ou dans une
dictature vous n'auriez même pas pu
adresser la question que vous venez
d'adresser au Premier
[Musique]
ministre vous prétendez défendre les
institutions mais vous les piétinez
vous-même avec ce type de propos oui la
France est une grande démocratie oui
notre pays connaît des difficultés oui
ces difficultés se traduisent par des
débats politiques qui sont très souvent
difficiles oui nous sommes amenés pour
pouvoir agir pour pouvoir avancer à
devoir utiliser ça a été le cas notre
Constitution toute notre Constitution
rien que notre Constitution en laissant
entendre l'inverse je le dis vous ne
respectez pas celles et ceux qui se
battent dans le monde pour vivre en
démocratie et vous pvez je le crois la
voix à ceux qui sont les véritables
ennemis de notre démocratie et de notre
République je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre madame la
Présidente
madame la
Présidente le fait d'avoir enlevé le
président du corps pour avoir contester
dit la vérité des Français sur la
réforme des retraites la volonté de
vouloir dissoudre les soulèvements de la
terre les menaces de retirer les
financements aux associations qui vont
contre votre politique le fait d'assumer
de passer des lois qui vont à l'encontre
de notre constitution de notre règle
commune des valeurs vous ne voyez pas la
déchéance que vous êtes en train de
provoquer merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Panau pour le groupe la France
insoumise madame la Présidente nos
pensées se tournent d'abord vers nos
compatriotes réunionné et voisins
Mauriciens frappés par un cyclone nous
leur adressons notre entière
solidarité Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ceci n'est pas un remanimement
c'est un effondrement
artisan du malheur des Français depuis
bientôt 7 ans puis Premier ministre
depuis 7 jours d'un gouvernement que
vous n'avez pas choisi vous étiez
minoritaire en 2023 vous serez
minoritaire en 2024 car il n'a jamais
été question de changer de cap mais de
servir la bourgeoisie votre arrogance de
classe Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
la devez à une géographie exigue école
asacienne chancep cabinet ministériel
mais vos ministres sont hés jusque dans
le 6e arrondissement de Paris les
instances internationales s'inquiète des
libertés publiqu dans notre pays la
France est condamnée pour une action
climatique des personnes sans abri Meur
gelé dans la 7e puissance mondiale le
président multiplie les gesticulations
quand il ne savote pas les initiatives
qu'il a lui-même inauguré de la
convention citoyenne au rencontes de
Saint-Denis le voilà qui veut renouer le
débat avec les Français qu'il commence
par augmenter les salaires baisser les
prix l'énergie réquisitionner les
logements vides Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous AZ décé pour soutenir ces
golenes Royal vous finissez par recycler
les ministres de Nicolas Sarkozi ceci
n'est pas un remanimement c'est un
effondrement vous êtes Premier ministre
mais le monarque républicain gouverne
seul ce soir il présentera la politique
générale du gouvernement à votre place
ceci n'est pas un remanimement c'est un
effondrement au prix de toutes les
compromissions vous avez adopté une loi
immigration avec les voix et les idées
de l'extrême droite vous êtes le produit
d'une faillite morale et idéologique
pour la première fois de l'histoire des
invertébrés politiques sont au pouvoir
Monsieur le Premier Ministre allez-vous
enfin respecter le Parlement
souhaitez-vous poursuivre l'œuvre de
Madame B en faisant de la France la
risée démocratique ou comptez-vous
demander le vote de confiance comme tous
les premiers ministres depuis TR
décennies merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier
[Applaudissements]
Ministre merci madame la Présidente
mesames et messieursput madame la
Présidente Panau nouvelle année nouveau
Premier ministre nouveau gouvernement
mais il y a des choses qui ne changent
pas vous avez posé la question la plus
politicienne depuis le début de cette
séance de question au gouvernement
madame la Présidente
Panau vous
choisissez de parler de ma vie de mon
parcours j'ai vu aussi des expressions
sur celles et ceux de membres de mon
gouvernement moi je vais vous le dire de
manière très claire et ça nous
différencie manifestement même si vous
tenez souvent des discours qui sont
différents moi je ne regarde pas d'où
les gens viennent je regarde où ils
veulent aller je ne regarde pas les gens
pour ce qu'ils sont mais pour ce qu'ils
font je ne me soucierai jamais en
regardant mes ministres les
parlementaires tous les Français qui
veulent agir de leur couleur de peau de
leurs origines sociales géographique je
ne me soucierai jamais de ces sujets là
l'Ance c'est de vouloir agir pour les
Français vous avez abordé un sujet dans
votre question qui est un sujet
important effectivement celui du froid
et de nos concitoyens qui sont sans abri
évidemment que c'est un sujet et là je
crois que nous pouvons nous rassembler
humainement socialement qui nous indigne
et pour lequel nous avons tous à cœur
d'agir et madame la Présidente panneau
je vous mets au défi de me citer une
majorité qui comme celle-ci a sorti
550000 personnes du sansabrisme en leur
permettant d'avoir un logement pérenne
qui a doublé qui a doublé le parc doublé
le parc de l'hébergement d'urgence en le
portant à 200000 places nous avons
doublé les places d'hébergement
d'urgence encore il y a quelques jours
le gouvernement a annoncé des crédits
supplémentaires pour créer des places
d'hébergement supplémentaires pour nos
concitoyens qui sont en difficulté oui
madame la Présidente c'est un sujet qui
est très difficile humainement
socialement c'est un sujet sur lequel
nous allons continuer à nous engager par
deà les anathème par deà les critiques
politiciennes par deà les blocages et
les oppositions de celles et ceux qui ne
veulent pas que nous réglions les
problèmes des
Français merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre la parole est à monsieur
Guillaume vutet pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'intérieurs et des outres m monsieur le
ministre des vents à plus de 170 km/h
des milliers de foyers privés d'eau
d'électricité des milliers de personnes
déplacées l'île de la Réunion a frôé le
pire le cyclone Bilal la for fortement
impacté les dégâts sont importants
d'après les premières informations qui
nous parviennent mais il semble que le
cataclysme qui était au cœur de toutes
les craintes n'a pas eu lieu certes la
nature a peut-être épargné un peu et été
plus clémente que prévue à l'égard de
notre territoire mais c'est aussi parce
que ce territoire ser préparé avec
méthode à affronter ces événements qu'il
a tenu je veux saluer l'esprit de
responsabilité de civisme des
Réunionnais l'action efficace des
services de l'état des forces de secours
et de sécurité des agents des
collectivités locales et de leurs élus
qui ont préparé mise en œuvre et
respecté les mesures de protection
celles-ci ont permis de préserver au
mieux les vies les équipements et les
biens au moment où je vous parle il
semble qu'il n ait malheureusement une
victime qui soit déplorée je veux
transmettre notre soutien à sa famille
et à ses proches je veux aussi au nom de
notre de mon groupe mais j'ai rejoignant
cela l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale vous demander de transmettre
notre salut fraternel au réunionnais que
vous allez rejoindre dès ce soir je veux
le demander aussi à nos collègues
députés de la Réunion qui sont sur leur
territoire quand un territoire dans la
nation est ainsi frappé il n'y a plus de
place pour l'éclivage il n'y a que
l'union et la solidarité monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement a décidé de
mobiliser des moyens importants pour
réparer ce qui doit l'être accompagner
nos compatriotes dans leur démarchees il
semblerait par exemple qu'à la demande
du Président de la République et du
Premier ministre des renforts de
sécurité civile des gendarmes ainsi que
des agents d'énéice a été envoyés sur
place je souhaite donc que vous
précisiez la représentation nationale
l'état de la situation et le détail de
ce qui va être mis en œuvre pour que l'
se relève au plus vite apprenne de cet
épisode dans le contexte des changements
climatiques et face lesestigmat de cette
catastrophe je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
Dar ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outres
Maes merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Guillaume Vilet j'ai évidemment
une pensée pour l'ensemble des
réunionnés et malheureusement nous avons
découvert manifestement deux autres
corps qui seraiit ceux de cque fil qui
aurait refusé l'hébergement d'urgence il
y aurait donc eu trois morts lors de ce
cyclone à la Réunion je vaux évidemment
m'incliner devant leur leur mémoire et
saluer comme vous l'avez fait les
services de l'État en lien avec les
collectivités locales et singulièrement
le travail exceptionnel du préfet Jérôme
philippini qui grâce à son action et à
celle de la sécurité civile des pompiers
des policiers des gendarmes et des élus
locaux ont sauvé de très nombreuses vies
à la
Réunion à la demande du Président de la
République et du Premier ministre je me
rends ce soir à La Réunion pour y être
demain d'abord pour pouvoir constater
que les services de l'État mété au
France en premier monsieur le ministre
Christophe Béchu a su alerter à temps le
travail pour cette île mais aussi a pu
protéger grâce à la vigilance rouge et
le confinement décidé par le préfet de
très nombreuses ves et grâce à ce que
nous avons mis en place collectivement
le système fr alerte a permis à chacun
et à chacun partout sur le territoire de
la réunion de pouvoir vivre dans des
conditions évidemment très dégradées
mais qui permettent de sauver un maximum
de vie et bien sûr un maximum de biens
demain je me rendrai à plusieurs
reprises auprès bien sûr des
agriculteurs des des travailleurs des
habitants de La Réunion ce sera
l'occasion pour moi aussi de répondre à
leur demande de connaissance de
catastrophe naturelle pour une partie
d'entre eux et répondent aussi aux
questions de calamité agricole qui
concne les agriculteurs en lien avec
Marc fenau ce sera aussi pour moi
l'occasion de dire au nom du
gouvernement notre solidarité avec l'île
Maurice qui est touché également et je
sais que le premier ministre et
président de la République pourront
proposer dans les prochaines heures la
sécurité civile et les moyens du
ministère de l'Intérieur et des autres
ministères bien sûr du gouvernement de
la République en protection des biens et
des personnes à l'île Maurice qui est
également touché comme la réunion je
vous remercie merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Fabien
Roussel pour le groupe
GDR je souhaite à mon tour apporter la
solidarité la plus totale à la
population réunionnaise et que l'on soit
à côté d'elle en ces moments très très
dur qu'elle vit en CE
momentour
conductrice de carart scolaire je fais
48 km par jour pour me rendre à mon
travail je commence à 7h du matin 5
jours par semaine je gagne à peine plus
que le RSA je n'ai pas le droit à la
prime d'activité car mon conjoint est
agriculteur avec des revenus trop élevés
et en plus je dois faire faire mon plein
pour aller travailler mon salaire
687,67 € je suis salarié d'une
entreprise textile à Saint-Étienne j'ai
34 ans d'ancienneté heureusement que ma
fille de 27 ans vit avec moi et M
financièrement mon salaire
1661,49 avec 34 ans d'ancienneté
Monsieur le Premier Ministre voilà deux
exemples parmi des centaines que nous
recevons depuis que le Parti communiste
français a lancé cette campagne
opération vérité sur les salaires et
demander aux salariés de leur envoyer
leur fiche de paye c'est un déferlement
plein d'émotion mais aussi de colère les
Français placent depuis des années la
question du pouvoir d'achat de la fichè
de l'inflation en tête de toutes leurs
préoccupations et on les comprend tout
augmente hormis les salaires hormis le
SMIC tout augmente sauf les salaires
hormis le SMIC et en plus aujourd'hui
vous voulez encore augmenter le prix de
l'électricité au 1er février tout ça
c'est le fruit de votre politique c'est
celle d'une caste qui a très bien servi
les plus riches habimer nos services
publics et attaquer nos acquis sociaux
comme la retraite Monsieur le Premier
Ministre les Français de l'Hexagone
comme de l'outrem ne demandent pas
l'homone ils veulent de la justice
sociale et c'est ce que nous proposons
indexé des salaires sur l'inflation
divisé par TR les prix de l'électricité
grâce au nucléaire et investir dans les
services publics comme l'école et la
santé alors monsieur
minist allez-v enfin changer de cap
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire ministre de l'Économie
des Finances de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique oui madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
Rousell je vous rejoins totalement sur
la nécessité d'avoir de meilleures
rémunérations pour tous les salariés
dans notre pays la première condition
pour cela je pense que vous me
rejoindrez c'est qu'il y ait le maximum
de salariés num et l'une des grandes
réussites de cette majorité c'est
d'avoir augmenté le nombre de salariés
en ayant le taux d'emploi le plus élevé
depuis 40 ans dans notre pays c'est la
première condition il faut des salariés
pour avoir des salaires la deuxième
chose c'est de protéger les
rémunérations de ceux qui ont les
salaires les plus faibles c'est le SMIC
et là je suis en désaccord avec vous
s'il y a une rémunération qui a beaucoup
augmenté au cours des deux dernières
années c'est le SMIC qui a augmenté de
plus de 10 % parce que nous sommes le
seul pays où il est indexé à la fois sur
l'inflation et sur la moyenne des
salaires le SMIC protège bien l'ensemble
de nos compatriotes trè chose Monsieur
Rousel ve avec nous l'augmentation de la
prime d'activité vote avec nous la prime
Macron défiscalisé qui a profité à 5
millions de salariés pour une moyenne de
près de 700 € par an pour les salariés
votez avec nous ce que vous avez
toujours refusé qui est pourtant une
mesure de justice fondamentale pour tous
les ouvriers et pour tous les salariés
fiscalisation des heures supplémentaires
qui fait plus de rémunération pour tous
ceux qui
travaillent enfin Monsieur Roussel nous
protégeons les plus modestes j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure que nous avions
fait le choix avec le président de la
République avec le Premier ministre
d'indexer l'ensemble des prestations
sociales et l'ensemble des minimas
sociaux sur l'inflation j'ai fait le
choix hier alors qu'il m'était proposé
de baisser à un peu plus de 4,5 % la
rémunération de vira d'éparne populaire
de mettre cette rémunération à 5 % pour
que la rémunération de l'épne des plus
modestes soit supérieure à l'inflation
c'est une protection de l'épargne des
plus modestes enfin recréer de la
dynamique salariale regardeer ensemble
comment est-ce que nous pouvons
reprofiler les allègements de charges
pour recréer la dynamique salariale nous
y sommes prês et nous y travaillons
ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
Président marangi pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le Premier ministre le groupe
horison et apparenté tient tout d'abord
à saluer votre nomination ainsi que
celle de votre gouvernement je souhaite
également saisir cette occasion pour
saluer l'ensemble du travail effectué
pendant 20 mois par votre prédécesseur
madame la Première ministre ellisabeth
borne je le
dis je le dis sans triomphalisme nous
avons pris les décisions que les
circonstances exigaient dans le sens de
l'intérêt général
nous en sommes convaincus la majorité
présidentielle doit être au rendez-vous
des espoirs et des attentes de nos
concitoyens se conformer à cette
impératif c'est faire des années qui
viennent un temps utile pour la France
partenaire sérieux partenaire loyal mais
partenaire exigeant c'est ainsi que nous
concevons d'accompagner votre action
résolue en ce sens l'échec n'est pas
permis c'est pourquoi notre
détermination demeure sans faille notre
groupe fera preuve de constance dans la
suite de nos débats parlementaires en
restant particulièrement attentif à la
poursuite du débat engagé sur les
grandes priorités de notre temps
l'excellence à l'école afin que chaque
jeune et les moyens de réaliser
pleinement son potentiel la réforme de
notre système de santé avec notamment la
lutte contre les déserts médicaux la
revalorisation du travail afin que
celui-ci paye pour toute personne qui
contribue à l'effort productif de notre
pays le maintien d'une politique
économique ambitieuse qui ne perd pas de
vue l'objectif de baisse de nos déficits
tout en étant garant d'attractivité de
compétitif
et donc de prospérité la transition
écologique sous l'autorité de Monsieur
le Ministre Christophe Béchu ainsi que
la transition énergétique Monsieur le
Premier Ministre les thématiques que je
viens de citer correspondent aux
préoccupations majeures des Français
ainsi pouvezous indiquer à la
représentation nationale comment
celles-ci vont trouver leur place dans
la politique menée par votre
gouvernement je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président la parole
est à Monsieur le Premier Ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président
marcangéi je vous remercie pour votre
question et l'état d'esprit qui est le
vôtre comme celui des groupes modem du
groupe renaissance de la majorité
présidentielle qui consiste tout
simplement à se poser une question qui
peut paraître simple mais qui me semble
être le B àas quelles sont les attentes
concrètes de nos concitoyens et comment
pouvons-nous y répondre et dans la
question qui est la vôtre vous avez
abordé ce qui constitue pour moi les
attentes profondes de nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui faire effectivement que le
travail paye plus et que travailler soit
toujours plus intéressant que ne pas
travailler ça paraît là aussi une forme
de BÉABA mais malheureusement je
constate régulièrement dans le débat
politique que ça ne l' pas pour tout le
monde et que pour d'autres il s'agit
d'un objectif
annexe insiste et continue à le faire
sur le fait que c'est le travail qui
crée la richesse qui nous permet ensuite
de financer nos services publics et la
solidarité
c'est le travail qui nous permet de
redistribuer c'est le travail qui nous
permet d'investir dans les services
publics certains manient la taxe l'impôt
supplémentaire comme un préalable à
toute chose et en faisant cela
finalement il nuirait à la compétitivité
de notre pays au travail dans notre pays
et donc aux recettes qui nous permettrai
d'investir pour les Français nous sommes
parfaitement alignés de ce point de
vue-là sur les services publics majeurs
que constitue l'école et la santé oui ce
sont des priorités absolues sur
lesquelles nous allons accélérer j'aurai
l'occasion là aussi dans ma déclaration
de politique générale après avoir
rencontré l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires les associations d'élus
les organisations syndical d'indiquer
comment est-ce que je souhaite avancer
avec vous sur ces sujets et oui sur la
planification écologique grâce à
Christophe Béchu nous avons maintenant
depuis plusieurs mois une planification
qui a été dressée par le Président de la
République la première ministre décliné
par le ministre Christophe Béchu pour
continuer je le dis à faire de la France
une nation en Europe qui s'engage encore
plus que les autres sur la transition
écologique et là aussi j'entends les
débats là aussi j'entends les critiques
j'attend qu'on me présente un pays qui
sur les questions énergétiques sur les
questions climatiques sur les questions
de transition investit et agit autant
que nous le faisons en France nous
allons continuer à le faire et je me
réjouis de le faire avec vous monsieur
le Président marcangéi et votre groupe
je vous remercie monsieur le Premier
ministre la parole est à Madame Valérie
Baz mal gr pour le groupe les
républicains
merci merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous venez d'annoncer 32 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour le système
de santé c'était une annonce
spectaculaire sauf qu'en réalité ces 32
milliards d'euros ne sont pas nouveaux
et ont déjà été votés au vu de la
situation de notre système de santé on
ne peut pas jouer avec les hospitaliers
et l'ensemble des acteurs du monde de la
santé le jetant de la poudre aux yeux
vous ne faites qu'accroître la déception
et le désarroi de nos personnels
soignants à qui je veux d'ailleurs
rendre
hommage car oui la réalité de la France
de 2024 c'est que l'hôpital est en crise
et que nos éepad sont dans une situation
financière dramatique les personnels
soignants malgré leur dévouement et leur
travail sont à bout de souffle trop
souvent débordés et ce sont les
résidents et leurs familles qui en P le
prix fort enfin sur tous les territoires
les épates sont au bord de l'asfixie
financière incapa de boucler leur budget
et vous le savez bien Monsieur le
Premier Ministre à l'heure du
vieillissement de la population votre
gouvernement doit faire de la question
de l'autonomie et du grand âge une
priorité pour notre pays depuis 2017 le
président Macron nous promet le
financement de la 5e branche de la
sécurité sociale et nous ne voyons
toujours rien venir
alors contrairement à vos
prédécesseurs allez-vous enfin être le
premier ministre des promesse tenu il y
a urgence à ce que vous répondiez
rapidement aux demandes de nos hôpitaux
et de nos éepad je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Catherine Vautrin ministre du
Travail de la santé et des solidarités
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Valérie Bazin malgra madame la députée
votre question est évidemment l'occasion
de répondre et aux professionnels de
santé en leur rendant hommage à la fois
pour leurs compétences et leur
engagement qu'ils soient
libéraux qu'ils soient libéraux ou
qu'ils soient hospitaliers parce
qu'effectivement l'hôpital c'est notre
trésor national et que nous allons très
concrètement investir massivement pour
l'hôpital et que nous allons précisément
accélérer ces investissements les
crédits sont là il y a une seconde
madame la députée vous faisiez allusion
à des crédits votés et je pense que nous
allons nous retrouver sur le fait que
c'est bien de créer de voter des crédits
c'est encore mieux de les dépenser et
donc l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est très
concrètement d'accélérer cette démarche
pour que ces crédits deviennent réalités
que nos établissements de santé qu'il
soi hospitaliers médicauxsociaux voi
effectivement l'évolution ce sont les
chiffres que j'ai déclinés tout à
l'heure et si je reviens sur ce sujet je
voudrais rappeler l'importance de la
coopération entre les professionnels
nous l'avons vu avec Monsieur le Premier
Ministre à Dijon samedi où nous avons
visité des urgences qui étaient des
urgences pédiatriques qui venaient
d'être refaite une déclinaison tout à
fait précise et quelque part c'est le
secret d'un système de santé qui soit à
l'échelle du bassin de vie car ce que
vous venez de décrire madame la députée
n'est rien d'autre que la attente de nos
concitoyens qu'ils soi en ville qu'il
soi dans la dans la ruralité alors mon
objectif ma feuille de route au bout de
3 jours est extrêmement clair je vous le
dis très calmement madame la députée
vociféré ne sert à rien l'objectif c'est
de garantir une offre de soins dans tous
les bassins de vie à chacun quel que
soit l'âge de la
vie je vous remercie madame la députée
madame la ministre j'ai bien entendu
votre réponse vous nousvez part de votre
feuille de route maintenant allez-y vous
avez les clés vous avez le budget donc
on vous attend madame la ministre pour
nos épades et pour nos
hôpitaux
merci la parole est à présent au
président vot pour le groupe
socialiste madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Premier Ministre vous vous présentez
devant nous après la loi immigration
grave et coupable faillite politique et
morale normalisant comme jamais
l'extrême droite et ses idées vous vous
présentez devant nous avec un
gouvernement qui fait figure d'aveux fin
du en même temps et cohabitation assumée
avec la droite dure après la préférence
nationale voici la préférence Sarkozi
vous vous présentez devant nous avec un
gouvernement incomplet où sont les
ministre du Logement des Transports de
la fonction publique tandis que
Messieurs darin le maire le Cornu se
sont nommés eux-mêmes et que d'autres
vous ont été imposé par le Président de
la République vous présentez devant nous
avec une ministre de l' am qui a
combattu le mariage pour tous et s'est
opposé à la protection de l'IVG devant
le Conseil constitutionnel avec une
ministre de l'éducation qui méprise
l'école publique et ses professeurs ex
avec une ministre de la culture dont
tous les votes à la ville de Paris
témoigne du peu d'intérêt qu'elle porte
à la culture populaire vous vous
présentez devant nous avec une ministre
mise en examen et la part des femmes
dans le gouvernement réduite à la
portion congrue la République exemplaire
et la grande cause du quinquenard
attendront encore vous vous présentez
devant nous sans avoir prononcé votre
déclaration de politique générale
attendant que le Président de la
République don vous ne cessez d'être le
collaborateur donne son son interview et
ses instructions au mépris du
gouvernement Monsieur le Premier
Ministre êtes-vous le chef du
gouvernement êtes-vous le chef de la
majorité de quelle majorité êtes-vous
responsable devant la représentation
nationale je vous remercie monsieur le
président
[Applaudissements]
ah vous avez terminé oui monsieur le
Premier
ministre comme vous preniez une deuxième
feuille je me suis dit continue continue
plus
tard merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Boris Vallot je rectifie mon
président Boris Vallot je rectifie mon
propos de tout à l'heure c'est en fait
vous qui avez posé la question la plus
politicienne depuis le début de cette
séance et vous décrochez pour ça la
médaille d'or qu'avait mathil Panau
jusqu'à
maintenant monsieur le Président Valot
monsieur le Président Valot j'assume
totalement j'assume totalement s'il vous
plaît j'assume totalement de considérer
d'avoir considéré depuis 2017 et de
continuer à le faire que face au défis
que rencontre notre pays face aux
difficultés que traversent les Français
nous devons nous retrousser les manches
avec des personnes qui viennent
d'horizon politique différents et moi
monsieur Vall je le dis et je l'assume
aussi de manière très claire vous me
reprochez mon gouvernement et des
personnalités qui font parti de ce
gouvernement moi je vais vous dire je
préfère travailler avec rachidti
Catherine vaterin comme moi qu'avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon comme vous
voilà ça nous
différencie nous n'avons pas les mêmes
valeurs pas les mêmes
objectifs priorités chacun les
personnalités avec lesquelles il
souhaite s'associer pour le reste
monsieur Valot s'il vous plaît pour le
reste je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
l'important pour moi ça n'est pas de
regarder d'où viennent les uns et des
autres c'est de garantir qu'ils veulent
aller dans la même direction et c'est le
cas de cette équipe gouvernementale et
de cette majorité l'important pour moi
ça n'est pas de demander à mes ministres
de vider leur poches pour regarder
quelle est la carte du parti politique
dans lequel ils étaient parfois il y a
plusieurs années l'Ance c'est de
regarder ce qu'ils ont dans le ventre et
ce qu'ils ont envie de faire pour notre
pays je l'assume
totalement l'important monsieur Valot ça
n'est pas de se jeter des anathèmes à la
figure encore une
fois l'important ça n'est pas d'enfermer
les uns et les autres dans des positions
qu'ils ont pu tenir j'ai envie de vous
dire encore heureux qu'il y ait des
Français qui puissent changer d'avis il
en a eu des millions qui ont changé
d'avis sur un certain nombre de grands
débats que vous avez évoqué ça s'appelle
une démocratie ça s'appelle la liberté
de conscience et c'est un trésor pour
notre pays et moi je continuerai à le
défendre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Premier ministre monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Président Monsieur le Premier ministre
vous avez un cap à droite toute vous
êtes comme dirait Clémenceau la gauche
en poau de lapin vous prétendez écouter
les Français les oppositions voici
quelques suggestions augmente les saair
rétablissez l'isfeleer les tarifs de
l'électricité rétablissez les postes que
vous avez supprimé dans l'éducation
nationale pour que votre Ministre
peut-être consente à y inscrire ses
enfants
je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Sandrine
joso pour le groupe
démocrate
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
c'est avec beaucoup d'émotion que je
reviens parmi vous aujourd'hui je tiens
à tous vous remercier pour votre soutien
et particulièrement vous madame la
Présidente le 14 novembre dernier je
suis allée chez un ami le cœur léger
pour fêter sa
réélection j'en suis ressortie
terrorisée
j'ai découvert un
agresseur je comprends alors que j'ai
été drogué à mon insu c'est ce qu'on
appelle la soumission
chimique ce fait société est un fléau
qui fait des milliers de victimes du
berceau à l'épad du bureau à la maison
de la boîte de nuit à la soirée entre
amis tout se trouve dans votre armoire à
pharmacie
9 fois sur 10 la victime est une femme
et dans 70 % des cas elle subira une
agression
sexuelle
aujourd'hui je ne vous parle pas en tant
que femme victime mais en tant que
député de la nation qui s'indigne que ce
sujet ne soit pas pris à
bras-lecp j'en appelle le gouvernement
et plus particulièrement vous madame la
ministre la France est grande quand elle
est juste c'est un slogan des années 90
qui a toute son actualité
aujourd'hui Caroline Darian et le
collectif mandorpa ont interpellé à
l'automne dernier les pouvoirs publics
pour que la lutte contre la soumission
chimique fasse l'objet d'un travail
conjoint car ces violences sont devenues
à la fois des question d'ordre public de
santé de justice et
d'éducation alors madame la ministre que
répondez-vous à leur cri du cœur
seriez-vous d'accord pour mettre les
moyens de l'État au service du combat
contre ce
phénomène pour mieux le cerner et enfin
trouver le moyen de sortir toutes les
victimes de l'oubli je compte sur
vous
merci beaucoup madame la
députée merci beaucoup la parole est à
Madame or berger ministre chargé de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et de la lutte contre la
discrimination merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée et
permettez-moi de vous dire chère
Sandrine merci merci pour votre courage
d'abord le courage de vous lever dans
cet hémicycle et le courage de parler le
courage de témoigner et de vous exposer
le courage surtout de faire de ce combat
non pas juste le vôtre mais celui qui
doit être celui de toute notre société
car c'est désormais un combat dont vous
vous êtes emparé et un combat dont vous
voyez que l'ensemble de cet hémicycle
cette emparé les droits des femmes vous
le savez nous le savons méritent des
combattants et des combattantes je crois
que vous êtes résolument une de ces
combattantes la question que vous
soulevez de la soumission chimique est
un sujet qui mérite nulle polémique mais
qui Nérite une mobilisation de la
société tout entière pendant trop
longtemps nous avons cru que la
soumission chimique c'était uniquement
ce qui pouvait arriver au desour d'une
soirée c'était du GHB versé dans un
verre ce que vous avez traversé ce que
Caroline Darian au travers de sa mère a
traversé c'est que ça peut arriver dans
la plus parfaite intimité peut être un
compagnon ça peut être un conjoint ça
peut être un parent ça peut être
prétendument un ami la loi a changé la
loi a changé le garde des saau en est le
garant de manière à ce que justement
évidemment toutes les victimes soient
considérées car depuis la loi 2018 c'est
bien un fait aggravant pour la question
du viol et c'est même devenu un délit à
part entière mais oui oui nous devons
aller plus loin aller plus loin pour
mobiliser l'ensemble de la société aller
plus loin pour mieux former aller plus
loin pour mieux accompagner les victimes
parce que nous le savons les dégâts qui
existent psychologiques notamment
peuvent faire durer des semaines des
mois voir des années après au travers de
l'amnésie et de l'amnésie traumatique
pendant trop longtemps nous n'avons pas
écouté les femmes lorsqu'elles parlaient
aujourd'hui la société les écoute non
seulement nous les écoutons mais nous
leur disons que nous les croyons et nous
sommes à leur côté merci merci beaucoup
madame la
ministre la parole est à monsieur
Alexandre Loubet pour le rassemblement
nationale merci madame la Présidente au
nom du groupe du Rassemblement national
permettez-moi tout d'abord d'avoir une
pensée pour nos compatriotes réunionnés
en ces jours
difficiles ma question s'adressa
initialement au ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères qui brille
malheureusement par son absence en ce
premier jour de séance de question au
gouvernement je vous interroge donc
monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
nommé monsieur séjourné à la tête du K
d'orsé pour représenter et défendre les
intérêts de notre pays pourtant les
Français doivent savoir que le 22
novembre 2023 au Parlement européen
monsieur séjourné a appelé à la fin de
notre souveraineté nationale en votant
pour le rapport
verofstad en effet par ce vote
symbolique de votre Ministre et de vos
députés
vous soutenez la mise en place d'un
Président d'un gouvernement et d'une
armée pour l'Union européenne vous
voulez soumettre notre droit national à
l'arbitraire des juges européens vous
souhaitez renforcer les pouvoirs de
l'Union européenne au détriment des
États en matière de santé d'écologie de
sécurité de défense ou encore de
politique étrangère et surtout par ce
vote vous voulez mettre fin à la règle
de l'unanimité dernier garant de notre
souveraineté au Conseil européen
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous voulez
donc priver la France de son droit de
vetto droit de veto qui pourtant nous
protège de toute décision qui porterait
atteinte à nos intérêts vitaux par ce
vote Monsieur le Premier Ministre votre
gouvernement dévoile son intention il
dévoile l'intention d'Emmanuel Macron de
dissoudre la France dans un État fédéral
européen ma question est donc simple
Monsieur le Premier Ministre comment
prétendez-vous vouloir représenter et
défendre notre pays alors qu'il y a 2
mois seulement votre ministre des
Affaires étrangères a voté pour la
disparition de la
France je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame Prisc t ministre en charge du
renouveau démocratique et porte-parole
du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député Loubé j'avoue être un
peu étonné je ne sais pas trop à qui je
m'adresse aujourd'hui est-ce que je
m'adresse au députés national ou au
directeur de campagne d'un homme en
campagne en ce moment parce que oui vous
voulez parler des votes et ben parlons
des votes je pourrais parler en long et
en large de vos votes au sein de cet
hémicycle vous le savez très bien j'ai
été plus haut dans cet hémicycle pour
témoigner du non travail et de
l'incompétence qui règne parmi vos r
mais parlons plutôt de vos votes au
niveau de l'Europe de vos votes parce
que oui vous votez vous votez contre les
soutien à l'Europe vous votez contre le
fait de dénoncer la main mise en ce
moment de Poutine sur l'attaque qu'il
est en train de mener contre l'Ukraine
vous votez contre le projet qui permet
de défendre nos frontières européenne
avec le pacte asile et migration mais
tout ça vous ne le savez pas et c'est
vrai je ne peux pas vous en vouloir la
raison est simple c'est que justement la
personne pour laquelle vous faites
campagne en ce moment est bien plus
souvent en train de faire campagne pour
elle-même que pour travailler pour les
Français je vous remercie madame la
ministre monsieur
l min accusation sont fausses et le 9
juin aux élections européennes les
Français bloqueront votre projet
fédéraliste je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
Charlotte parmanti le pour le groupe
Renaissance merci merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre du Travail de la
santé et des solidarités madame la
ministre je tiens tout d'abord à vous
féliciter pour votre nomination à la
tête de ce grand ministère et en tant
que présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales je me réjouis de notre
collaboration sur ces sujets majeurs qui
touchent en profondeur la vie de nos
concitoyens depuis près de 50 ans grâce
au courage de Simon veille les femmes en
France ont le chix ont le droit de
disposer de leur corps et de faire le
choix d'une interruption volontaire de
grossesse et je veux ici saluer les
professionnels qui les accompagne dans
cette épreuve souvent vécue
douloureusement la liberté de recourir à
l'IVG est un droit fondamental et je
remercie le président de la République
d'avoir pris la décision forte de
protéger ce droit en l'inscrivant dans
la
Constitution vous savez que notre
majorité est extrêmement engagée à la
préservation de ce droit et à en
garantir l'effectivité pour toutes les
femmes je rappellerai que c'est notre
majorité qui a allongé le délé légal
d'IVG de 12 à 14 semaines c'est notre
majorité aussi qui a élargi l'accès à l'
iivg médicamenteuse et étendu les
compétences des sages femmes pour
pratiquer des IVG
instrumentales madame la ministre
l'engagement des professionnels est une
condition syéquanone pour garantir la
réalité de ce droit et une juste
reconnaissance est attendu de leur part
or depuis 2016 les tarifs de l'IVG n'ont
pas été revalorisés et ne réflètent plus
la réalité des coûts aussi madame la
ministre je souhaite savoir quelle
mesure vous entendez prendre pour
remédier à cette situation et réaffirmer
la reconnaissance des professionnels
pour garantir l'accès à l'IVG pour
toutes je vous remercie madame la
Présidente la parole est à Madame
Catherine Vautrin ministre du Travail de
la santé et des solidarités madame la
Présidente Charlotte Parmentier Lecoq à
mon tour comme vous de rendre hommage à
Simone veille vous venez de le dire la
loi aura 49 ans demain c'est une loi du
17 février
1975 et vous avez avez tout à fait
raison il est absolument important que
nous puissions accompagner les
professionnels qui se sont engagés dans
cette démarche votre question est
extrêmement précise je vais vous
répondre de manière tout aussi précise
en vous disant que dans les toutes
prochaines semaines j'ose à peine dire
les tous prochains jours nous allons
mettre en place la revalorisation des
tarifs de l'IVG de 25 %. donc les choses
sont claires elles seront faites et
d'autre part bien évidemment je veux en
profiter pour dire combien avec mon
collègue le garde des saau nous allons
travailler avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires et ce sera notre honneur
monsieur le garde des saau que d'être
celui et celle qui auront la
responsabilité d'inscrire le droit à
l'avortement dans le marbre de notre
Constitution je vous remercie madame la
[Musique]
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Rodrigo Arenas pour le groupe la France
insoumise présidente bonjour chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de l'Enseignement
Privé j'ai bataillé durant des années
pour que l'école publique et laïque
donne à nos enfants à tous nos enfants
le meilleur de ce que la République peut
leur offrir mes combats je les ai menés
au côté des milliers d'autres parents
que vous avez méprisé insultés en
quelques
déclarations vous vous êtes simplement
moqué de ses élèves et de leurs parents
qui voit chaque année des centaines
d'heures d'enseignement de mathématiques
de français ou de Langle disparaître en
prétendant avoir subi un paquet d'heures
non remplacé en petite section de
maternelle situé dans l'un des quartiers
les plus hupés de
Paris toutes ces militantes et tous ces
militants de l'école publique toutes
celles et ceux qui n'ont pas fait le
choix de la résocratie méritent mieux
alors vous vous qui esttes une partisane
du mérite sans vous soucier d'ailleurs
de ce qui relève du mérite de l'argent
ou du Mérite du talent je vous le
dis vous ne méritez plus d'être la
ministre de l'Éducation
nationale car si l'on en croit ce que
disait Voltaire la politique c'est l'art
de mentir à propos manifestement vous
vous avez manqué d' propos donc ma
question madame la ministre de
l'Enseignement Privé est simple quand
allez-vous clore ce chapitre quand
démissionnerez-vous je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Amélie
oua Castera ministre de l'Éducation
Nationale de la Jeunesse des sports des
Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques madame madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Arenas à
peine nommé ministre de l'éducation
nationale j'ai été interpellée par mdiap
sur les choix de scolarisation
de mes enfants j'ai voulu y répondre
sans esquiver l'attaque je l'ai fait
avec
sincéritéil vous plaît je n'aurais pas
dû me laisser entraîner sur le terrain
de la vie
privée ni me sentir obligé de me
justifier aucun parent d'élèves ne
devrait l'être et je n'aurais pas dû non
plus exposer l'école
litré je suis allée à leur rencontre ce
matin pour m'en excuser et m'excuser de
les avoir blessé ces excuses je les leur
devais alors depuis vendredi j'ai tout
entendu les leçons de morale sur l'école
publique de la part de ceux qui mettent
leurs enfants dans l'école privée
l'agressivité de ceux qui rêveraient de
raviver une guerre entre l'école public
et l'école privée guerre qui n'existera
pas et ce weekend c'est mes valeurs
éducatives de mamans qui ont même été
mises en doute dans mes propos de
vendredi je me suis appuyé sur le
souvenir et le ressenti d'une expérience
d'il y a 15 ans où notre famille oui aé
sur des problèmes d'organisation comme
nous avons pu nous en souvenir avec
l'enseignante de l'époque avec qui j'ai
échangé alors maintenant avançons j'ai
de j'ai j'ai de l'ambition pour l'école
je veux soutenir toute la communauté
éducative pour remettre
social en
marche et faire grandir le mérite et le
talent c'est le sens du choc des savoirs
et de l'exigence voulue par le Premier
ministre des concertations engagées pour
le métier de professeur ce matin j'ai
échangé avec les enseignants de l'ITR
sur notre feuille de route pour l'école
publique et la problématique des
remplacements nous avons commencé à la
traiter nous irons jusqu'au bout car
c'est un problème que les Français des
millions de familles veulent que nous
traitions c'est en ce sens que je ferai
des propositions au Premier ministre
la desill je mesureneur fa de la servir
merci beaucoup madame la
ministre monsieur AR vous avez la
[Applaudissements]
parole madame cette affaire que vous
avez mis sur la place publique n'est pas
une affaire privée c'est une affaire
publique qui remet en question le
fonctionnement de l'éducation nationale
que manifestement vous connaissez pas
entre les propos que vous avez ten en
tant que ministre et non pas en tant que
maire de famille parce que vous avez le
droit de choisir l'école que vous le
souhaitez c'est la loi qui vous autorise
et les propos de cette enseignante qui
n'a pas manqué d'ors de cours j'ai
choisi mon camp madame j'ai choisi celle
des enseignants qui mettent plus que
leur salaire pour honorer le service
public d'éducation nationale je vous en
prie allez chercher l'argent privé que
vous avez pour faire en sorte que les
Jeux Olympiques se tiennent dans notre
pays et redonner à l'éducation nationale
c'est lettrre de noblesse que vous avez
abîmé en deux déclarations merci
beaucoup
s'il vous plaît la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre pont pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires monsieur le ministre
vous avez accompagné mardi dernier
quelques heures après sa nomination le
Premier ministre Gabriel hatal dans le
Pas de calé et je leur remercie très
sincèrement pour apporter le soutien de
la nation au sinistrés des inondations
depuis des semaines nous connaissons des
épisodes plusuvieux intense provoquant
des inondations exceptionnelles touchant
plus de 200 communes 2000 habitations
une centaine de PME une cinquantaine
d'exploitations agricole tous les moyens
de pompage nationaux et européens
étaient opérationnels dès le 6 janvier
mais la decrue est très très lente le
président Emmanuel Macron avait anncé
une première indemnisation de 50
millions d'euros pour aider les communes
à reconstruire les équipements publics
en commission des affaires européennes
nous avons également adopté un avis
politique visant à solliciter le fond de
solidarité européen les sinistrés de
tous ces événements catastrophiques
attendent des des réponses précises sur
les dédommagements possibles franchise
pour les entreprisees per d'exploitation
pour les commerçants PME et agriculteurs
et la mise en route rap des travaux à
entreprendre pour que de telles
situations ne puissent se reproduire à
l'avenir le Premier ministre vient
d'annoncer en faveur de ces sinistré des
Haut- de France n'aurait pas de calé le
lancement d'un plan de résilience je
vous serai fort reconnaissant de bien
vouloir nous en détailler le le contenu
merci je vous remercie monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Jean-Pierre pont
oui notre notre solidarité va évidemment
au réunionnais mais elle continue
d'aller au Pas de Calais dans lequel
vous l'avez dit la décru est extrêmement
lente et dans lesquel le gouvernement
sous l'autorité du nouveau Premier
ministre est entièrement mobilisé
j'associerai de manière très rapide Marc
F pour les calamités agricoles Bruno Le
Maire au titre des franchises
d'assurance et bien évidemment géralin
le ministre de ur au TI de la
reconnaissance de la catastrophe
naturelle de très nombreuses communes de
ce territoire et qui pour près de 200
d'entre elles ont été reconnu deux fois
en l'espace de 2 mois compenu à la fois
des pluies extrêmement fortes que nous
avons eu en novembre et d'un nouvel
épisode début janvier sur des sols
gorgés d'eau qui a conduit à ce que nous
connaissions de nouvelles crues de temps
monsieur le député d'abord l'urgence dés
hier sur le canal d'udr par exemple des
travaux de curage par VNF ont commencé d
hier
du côté de là des travaux là aussi pour
enlever les embacles ont été lancés et
tout un plan de très court terme et
d'urgence est lancé et il aboutira au
début du mois de février sur la
modification des règles concernant les
curages dans notre pays mais en
parallèle il faut se préoccuper du moyen
terme et le moyen terme ça a été le
premier acte administratif de notre
nouveau Premier ministre puisque le
premier document qu'il a signé c'est
cette mission sur un plan de résilience
qui vise trois objets le premier comment
quand on a des clés des sages des EPCI
des communes et qu'on a des territoires
qui sont à cheval sur deux départements
on fait en sorte d'avoir un
interlocuteur un chef pour coordonner
les travaux et donc ne serait-il pas
souhaitable d'avoir un établissement
public territorial de bassin pour mettre
tout le monde d'accord de comment on
regarde en face ce qui s'est passé pour
modifier le plan de prévention des
risques et des inondations et pour
constater qu'il y a peut-être des
territoires où à terme on ne pourra plus
habiter c'est le sens de ce plan de
résilience en en mobilisant les moyens
ce annoncer ceux qui le seront j'aurai
l'occasion dans les prochains jours de
retourner dans le pas decalis merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre monsieur
le député oui merci Monsieur le Ministre
la population bien sûr ne veut plus de
projet de promesses ou d'études elle
veut comme l'a dit le le Premier
ministre et comme vous venez de le dire
de l'action de l'action de l'action
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Mathilde Paris pour
le rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre du
Travail de la santé et des solidarités
fin 2020 le hashtag balance son stage
révélait les bisutages ignobles subis
par les étudiants en soins infirmiers
lors de stag en milieu hospitalier
clinique ou éepad bien que ces pratiques
soient interdites et constituent un
délit malgré les mois suscités par tous
les témoignages d'étudiants infirmiers
il y a 3 ans aujourd'hui rien n'a changé
l Amélie Sarah derrière non ce sont des
vies et des destins brisés elles avaient
toutes les trois en commun de vouloir
exercer un métier qui mettait au centre
l'humain et dans la France a cruellement
besoin peu avant Noël au cours de son
stage à l'hôpital Amélie a fait une
tentative de suicide elle ne supportait
plus l'humiliation permanente
l'inhumanité avec laquelle elle était
traitée la charge excessive de travail
incompatible avec des soins de qualité
lor en stage dans un centre hospitalier
vient de découvrir que son service
dispose d'une cagnotte à remporter par
celui ou celle qui arriverait à la faire
pleurer en premier quant à Sarah elle a
fait un burnout en plein stage et
subissait à longueur de journée les
humiliations des autres soignants tu es
nul tu ne sers à rien démissionne on va
fumer mais tu restes là tu eras pissa à
la fin de ta journée on ne veut pas te
voir entre 2019 et 2022 un/ers des
étudiants infirmiers a abandonné ses
études avant la fin du cursus une étude
du Journal du Dimanche réalisée il y a
un an révèle que 75 % des étudiants
infirmiers se disent épuisé physiquement
33 % confirment faire des crises
d'angoisse 26 % estiment être en
mauvaise santé psychique pour tenir 28 %
des sondés ont pris ou prennent des
psychotropes madame la ministre que
comptez-vous faire concrètement pour
mettre un terme définitif à ces
pratiques qui se répètent et dont les
victimes d'hier deviennent les bourreaux
de demain notre système de santé a
terriblement besoin d'infirmière et
d'infirmiers nous devons prendre soin de
nos étudiants pour qu'ils puissent être
à leur tour les soignants de demain
notre système de santé a terriblement
besoin de moyens et pas de fake news
comme celle des soi-disant 32 milliards
supplémentaires pour la santé annoncé
samedi par Gabrielle ATA lors de votre
déplacement conoint madame la députée la
parole est à Madame Catherine Vautrin
ministre du Travail de la santé et de
solidarité merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée ce que vous venez de décrire
est évidemment totalement inacceptable
et je pense que personne dans cet
hémicycle ne dira le contraire
maintenant l'engagement infirmier à
l'échelle du bassin de vie est
totalement indispensable il est aussi
bien indispensable à l'hôpital qu'il est
dans nos structures médicos-sociales
qu'il est également avec l'ensemble des
infirmiers infirmières libérales qui
sillonnent l'ensemble du territoire et
je pense particulièrement à la réalité
donc notre sujet c'est l'offre de santé
à proximité au service de tous à partir
de là vous avez raison le reconnaître ça
a été la revalorisation du Ségure pour
les Hospitaliers ce sont les mesures
salariales là encore pour les
Hospitaliers vous savez qu'actuellement
nous avons deux chantiers celui sur la
refondation du métier celui sur la
rénovation de la formation c'est dire si
quelque part dans la rénovation de la
sur de la formation il faut que nous
regardions effectivement la manière dont
les stages se passent et
particulièrement en milieu hospitalier
enfin je voudrais rappeler mes chers
mesdames et messieurs les députés
qu'après 10 ans de gel des quotas 6000
places de formation infirmière ont été
ouvertes et quelque part continuer à
travailler avec les infirmiers libéraux
hospital all à l'élargissement de leurs
compétences c'est une réponse qui est
celle qu'attendent nos concitoyens parce
que nous l'oublions jamais la présence
infirmière à proximité c'est pour
beaucoup notamment de nos aînés le
maintien à domicile qui est assuré je
vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur William Martinet
pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre car le président de la
République n'a pas déigné nommer un
ministre du L de plein exercice Monsieur
le Premier Ministre la vague de froid
qui traverse le pays provoque une
écatombe une femme dans le vauluse un
homme dans les hautes scèes un autre
dans le valdoise en seulement 4 jours
trois corps gelés ont été retrouvés dans
la rue une cave ou un abri de fortune
ces personnes n'ont pas été tuées par le
froid elles ont été tuées par la misère
elles sont les victimes de votre
politique la baisse des aPL
l'augmentation des loyers la case du
logement social l'accélération des
expulsions vous êtes responsable de ces
drames humain on se souvient du vote de
l'infamme loi casbariant du nom du
député pressenti pour être votre
Ministre du Logement cette loi réprime
les sansabri en les condamnant à 2 ans
de prison s'ils occupent un bâtiment
vide vous avez fait de la haine des
pauvres un critère pour devenir ministre
scandale dans le scandale celui des
enfants SDF des enseignants occupent
leur école pour mettre à l'abri des
élèves qui sinon passeraiit la nuit
dehors quelle réponse leur apportez-vous
encore et toujours la répression je
pense à institutrice convoqué par le
rectorat de Toulouse pour se justifier
de son acte de solidarité ces
enseignants sont l'honneur de la France
face à l'égoïsme social que vous
incarnez eux ils sont la République ses
principes ses valeurs ils sont la
fraternité inscrite sur le fronton des
écoles gloire à eux et honte à vous
l'année écoulée a été celle d'un double
record record du nombre de personnes
sans abri record des dividendes versé
aux actionnaires du CAC40 alors les
insoumis lanc un appel réquisition vous
entendez réquisition des logements
vacants qui sont plus dans 3 millions
dans le pays si vous n'en trouvez pas
nous vous aiderons à quelques centaines
de mètres d'ici métro sol ferino
l'association Droit au logement campe au
pied d'un immeuble osmanien vide vous
n'avez aucune excuse voilà pourquoi les
insoumis ont déposé plainte devant la
Cour de Justice de la République votre
inaction est coupable votre politique
tue vous avez des comptes à rendre à
toutes les bonnes volontés je dis
rendez-vous méro Solferino pour le droit
au logement
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Martinet
sincèrement j'aurait
aimé que de la même manière que ce cet
hémicycle dans un moment de silence qui
l'honore cont tenu de la gravité du
sujet quand la députée josau a pris la
parole au lieu de chercher à faire de la
petite politique vous essayez de vous
mettre précisément au niveau de ce
moment ce qui est historique est ce que
le record aujourd'hui c'est quoi ce sont
les niveaux d'hébergement d'urgence
historique qui ont été décidés dans ce
pays c'est plus du doublement du nombre
de places chaque soir ce sont 120000
personnes hébergées en île- de France
dans les dispositifs d'hébergement
d'urgence à cette réalité la semaine
dernière comme le premier ministre vient
de le rappeler ce sont 10000 NV
ave la G au thmomère 10000 nouvelles
plac 120 millions d'euros qui ont été
débloqué c'est depuis quelques jours
l'intensification des marudes c'est la
mise en place du plan grand froid dans
près de 60 départements c'est la
réquisition de gymnase d'école la mise à
l'abri de femm et d'homme et au milieu
de ça vous choisissez la polémique au
lieu de regarder comment nous pvons
améliorer nos dispositif au lie de ça
choisissez le dépô de plte au lieu de
soutenirire petit objet sincèrement dans
tous les pays d'Europe quel que soient
leurs orientations politiques la
question de la gestion du sensabrisme
est beaucoup trop complexe pour en faire
un baba montrez-vous à la hauteur de
l'événement soyez digne au lieu d'être
dans le dépôt de plainte regardez
comment nous pouvons avec les
collectivités locales avec les
associations avec les uns et les autres
travailler hier soir j'étais avec le
Samu Social j'étais en marude avec un
travailleur social une infirmière un
chauffeur je peux vous assurer que dans
leurs propos et dans ce que nous av r il
y avait bien plus de dignité que dans la
façon dont vous tentez de polémiquer sur
le
sujetci monsieur le ministre la séance
des questions gouvernement est terminée
la séance est
suspendue